president Trump will honor the president
of France tonight with the Trump
administration's first official state
dinner men will Matt Kroll and his wife
got a White House tour yesterday from
the President and First Lady Melania
Trump tonight's dinner will be held in
the state dining room major Garrett is
on the White House South Lawn where the
official ceremony welcoming the macarons
will be held shortly major good morning
good morning many world leaders are
invited to the White House a precious
few receive the honor of a state visit
so what's the point to take a strong
relationship between the American
president and that leader and make it
more resilient trusting and if possible
creative all of that will be required
for the United States and France as they
work through differences on Syria trade
and the future of the Iran nuclear deal
last night President Trump welcomed
French President Emmanuel macron at
George Washington's eighteenth-century
mansion in Mount Vernon Virginia the
relationship sealed awhile back with an
aggressive trumpian handshake and
regular phone calls since the French
president has said his was a friendly
relationship with mr. Trump it's very
easy as soon as he asked for coal III
going back and and exactly the same on
his side we have a very clear and open
discussion McCrone arrived with an
agenda persuade the president to keep US
troops in Syria and stay in the Iran
nuclear deal President Trump is leaning
against both president macros broken the
code with President Trump he's worked
the relationship Heather Conley a former
State Department official says this
state visit will highlight unity and
France's acceptance of an alliance with
mr. Trump this is a returning the
generous hospitality but also a way to
really to clearly state how strong a
partner France is McCrone treated the
president to the Bastille Day Parade in
Paris last year which included a tribute
to the 100th anniversary of US
involvement in World War one the
spectacle inspired plans for a grand
military parade in Washington in
November McCrone also treated the
President and mrs. Trump to an intimate
dinner at the top of the Eiffel Tower
it's in good hands I think mrs. Trump is
very involved and the staff seems to
love working
with her Jeremy Bernard with the social
secretary in charge of planning state
dinners for president and mrs. Obama
pull out all the stops make them feel
welcomed and make it as presidential as
possible
Barnard says there's not a lot that can
go wrong overall it's pretty scripted so
it just depends whether or not this
president stays on script the guest list
for tonight's state dinner still under
wraps though we are told most of the
political invitees are Republicans the
White House has told us of at least one
Democrat who was invited in will attend
Louisiana Governor John bel Edwards
Louisiana's ties to France fall into the
self-evident category the dinner tonight
well rack of lamb mostly American
cuisine with some french flourishes and
a pinot noir that carries the motto
French soul Oregon soil dill all right
it sounds very well-planned well the
table setting looked very pretty
yeah just said Melania Trump Stern
working really hard on it so major
covered every single detail the policy
well done mate oh well done come on Mac
Ron did not bring up the fact that
George Washington only surrendered once
to the French well there's still time
yeah so meetings all go for dinner
tonight